think a lot of what Andrew says is  hyperbole and I think it's exaggerated  and it's simply just an analogy the  first controversial comment which a lot  of people don't like that he said in the  interview was he compared women to  children no he doesn't literally think  women are children if he thought women  were children he wouldn't be sleeping  with women he's basically saying women  are not men women are delicate women are  emotional women need help whether it's  emotional support whether it's physical  support and all of these things I agree  with him he said that women are  difficult to travel with and I  understand that we get hungry and if  we're not fed we get angry so I  understand when he says women are  children we're emotional we need  emotional support and I think the older  I get the more I value men the more I  understand how men can provide stability  emotional stability they're that anchor  to reality which I think women really  need